alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
quoi de beau weekend dans les evvelines
sachez que ce weekend c'est la journée
internationale des légumineuses c'est
[Musique]
parti on est là c'est pour le faire si
je suis là c'est pour le faire
variété d'espèces
végétales survécu à travers les âges
pour raorter leur héritage n mange pas
trop c'est létal c'est souvent un
mauvais présage mais du son ça cache les
bruitages glcide protéin amidon imagine
tous les bienfaits pour ton bidon
calcium fibre fer si tu passes à côté tu
es vraiment on est là c'est pour le
faire on est là c'est pour le faire si
je suis là c'est pour le faire
on est là c'est pour le faire on est là
c'est pour le faire on est là c'est pour
le faire si je suis là c'est pour le
faire il est là on est là c'est pour le
faire petit pois petit petit pois petit
petit pois bois petit petit petit petit
petit bois petit petit petit bois petit
petit petit petit petit petit bois petit
petit petit petit petit petit petit
petit petit petit petit pois petit petit
petit petit petit petit
pois rajoute des Lupin comme arsenne
Lupin met des fèves à gauche à droite
pour préparer festin derrière on est
plein il en faut faut au moins 20 vas-y
bouge-toi et découpe pose la l verre de
20 met le sucre puis mélange puis je
l'étale dou mous je fais le taf puis tu
ranges la galette sors toute douce tu
fais pas le poid je t'ai cassé la vie tu
es rincée mais çaade puis je découpe il
y a plus qu'à déguster petit pois petit
petit pois petit petit pois bois petit
petit petit petit petit bois bois petit
bois bois petit petit bois petit petit
petit petit petit petit bois bois BO
petit petit petit petit petit petit
petit petit petit petit petit petit pois
légumineuse alors quoi de beau